celebrating his victory is first-time
candidate and newly elected mp usman
sangare
as member of the opposition sangre says
time has come to finally confront the
failures
of mali's ruling party
politics is not going well in mali mps
don't do what they are supposed to do
our elected officials have failed to
represent us
this will now change up until now
president ibrahim bubakar keta's party
rally for mali was unchallenged
in control of the parliament for the
past seven years after the president
canceled
elections twice on the grounds of
insecurity despite
more attacks from armed groups and the
coronavirus spreading the elections went
ahead in april
[Music]
second round went ahead as normal for
most of mali despite disruption from
terrorist groups in certain areas
the president's party won most of the
seats but failed to achieve an outright
majority
among the winners is muhammad uld matali
under u.n sanctions for his involvement
in
organized crime in association with
armed groups
matali won as a ruling party member in
gao
another winner opposition leader sumaila
say he won in mali's central region
despite being held in captivity
by armed groups who kidnapped him during
his campaign
while no one has claimed responsibility
his family suspects
militia groups closed to the government
for his abduction the government blames
an al-qaeda affiliate that group and the
islamic state in the greater sahara
called for a boycott of the vote
attacking polling stations military
outposts and threatening the population
filmed on mobile phone
an armed group using stolen military
vehicles seen patrolling
a village in mali's central region where
the malian army is retreating
fearing attacks and the coronavirus few
malians came out to vote with a record
low turnout of 23 percent
newspaper vendor micah mohammadin
believes the real winners of this
election
are armed groups
we are being held hostage mali is in the
hands of armed groups
they have surrounded us they have
destroyed villages
they are killing population and forcing
people from their homes
they have destroyed people's food
reserves i fear them more than anything
else
including the novel coronavirus four
million millions are in urgent need of
humanitarian assistance
many of them displaced it's become
sangaray's new job to not only represent
them but to hold a government to account
that has so far failed to bring peace to
mali
nicholas hawk al jazeera